si la france est laïque un objet est
pourtant sacralisé dans notre pays le
livre il y à 40 ans la loi lang sur le
prix unique imposé une règle qui fait
consensus le livre n'est pas un objet
commercial en librairie en grande
surface ou sur internet pas de
concurrence des prix sur un même ouvrage
ça nous permet non seulement d'avoir
beaucoup librairie doux de permettre aux
lecteurs d'aller où ils veulent de
choisir leur librairie petite grande et
surtout d'autres vais partout sur le
territoire est ce que ça permet aussi
aux lecteurs c'est de trouver énormément
de diversité de livres à dire que ce
prix unique du livre permet aussi
l'édition et la mise en vente d'un faune
extraordinaire qui fait aussi la
spécificité française en france sur les
25000 points devant vous vous pouvez
acheter un livre seulement 3000 sont des
librairies le prix unique permet donc
assez indépendant de résister mais
quarante ans après la loi est un peu
oublié peut-être que je le prenais pour
acquis parce que
c'est comme ça que je l'observais s'en
rendre compte donc
mais je ne sais vrai que je ne fais pas
de librairie en librairie pour faire des
comparaisons de prix ça permet de mettre
sur un pied d'égalité tous les
tous les magasins que ce soit librairie
supermarché ou
hulu qui nist si le prix d'un livre
n'est pas une source de concurrence les
frais d'envoi à un centime par les sites
marchands sont pointés du doigt ce
professionnel compte sur le bon sens
d'électeurs pour favoriser l'achat en
librairie en vous remerciant les gens
viennent aussi chercher un conseil bien
de chercher une nouveauté à lire est une
plateforme puis de dire mais ne peux pas
le permettre un forum ne le permettra
pas non plus il faut avoir des personnes
d'expérience permettant de proposer des
nouveautés et pas forcément que des
blockbusters
d'après le syndicat national de
l'édition plus de 420 millions de
volumes ont été vendus en 2020 le livre
une véritable passion française